I'm just trying to get closure at this
point
I'm thinking like going back to Barbados
literally all of
tyrae's mom and his other sister are in
Shock after he reveals he's been
catfished by Carmella for the last four
years
it mixed up in this I can't believe it
I'm still I'm confused and he shares why
he's still holding on to the catfish
after all the evidence points to the
fact that he was being scammed she gave
me like something I never really had
she
like told me that she loved me and stuff
so wow that statement right there says
so much
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia before
we get into Tyree Gino is in a Two Can
Play That Game mood with Jasmine and
although it is down a semi-petty route
I'm here for it we need to work on
communication this all comes after he
found out Jasmine's been communicating
with her ex Dane behind his back with my
ex-husband I was with him for nearly
eight years
one of our biggest struggles was
communication well I was with my ex-wife
and we never had any issues but you
ended up getting divorced Jasmine said
well something went wrong but I get
where Gina was coming from he's like
look my communication is not the problem
here but you ended up getting divorced
yeah but we were together for seven
years wow he's looking straight into the
camera what a sight to see in person
imagine being out in public and you turn
around and you see the 90-day camera
crew and you see Gino and Jasmine
standing there about to go at it this
would be me
they would have to use the intense blur
okay
all right after Gino brings up his ex
and says they had no issues with
communication Jasmine tells him it's
because their relationship was stale we
didn't argue we got along because you
were a boring relationship
ooh bird clearly Jasmine is not liking
the taste of her own medicine while you
bring up your ex
Gino tells her whatever she can do so
can he why did you bring up your ex
because I needed to give an example oh
okay but you think it's okay you can
bring up your ex and I can't because you
know that I get mad when you bring up
your ex it doesn't matter
if you can do it I'm gonna do it period
then you'll know what it feels like
oh once again it sounds Elementary and
cliche but treating others the way you
want to be treated is key unless you
like drama and Jasmine did say she
enjoys it but I need chaos I need
passion I need someone that is gonna
give me that fire you know once these
two really sit down to Hash things out
you always told me that I can't be
friends with my ex you fly off the
rocker even At The Mention Of My Ex's
names Gino asked Jasmine if she's
cheating on him with her ex Dane and she
says no but then she reveals to Gino
that Dane lives in her building out of
all the buildings in the freaking Panama
you got to pick the one that your ex is
in yeah he's my friend yeah a friend who
she admits to thinking about sleeping
with
it's not that I'm in love with him it's
not that I'm attracted to him
but
since when I want to have sex with you
you're never in the mood you don't want
me because you don't argue with me
like you reject me all the time
you are unlucky new levels of
insecurities in my life Jasmine goes on
to say that she doesn't fantasize about
Dane but because she and Gino barely get
into mid she allows herself to remember
how it was in her previous relationship
which sounds like fantasizing to me but
we'll let her have it overall what she's
saying sucks but it is understandable
it's dangerous
but again
understandable that's very very low do
you think it's okay that you fantasize
about having sex with him if our sexual
life we're better then we fantasize
about us
unbelievable their storyline ends with
Gino telling the camera he's losing his
trust in Jasmine here she is talking to
her acts fantasizing about him
physically seeing him moved into the
same building he's in this is bad it's
very bad y'all have been through worse
which raises the question
should it be this hard when do you just
say this is not working out speaking of
that tyrae is still having a hard time
with acceptance I'm trying to stay
hopeful but I'm more confused than ever
none of this lines up with you know the
Carmela I fell in love with this wasn't
hurt
maybe the person behind the text and
this woman in the photos are two
different people duh
danty go to a private investigator who
reveals Carmella is a cam porn star the
lady in these pictures her actual name
is Carmela or it's her alter ego name
but either way the pictures in her name
match up it said her name and underneath
United States
this is like she's like a fetish Queen
wow she is getting free advertisement on
90 Day Fiance I'm angry about the fact
that someone like got me with pictures
of a porn star and then at the same time
it's like I'm still a little confused
his sister is like bruh and the private
investigator is like oh okay this is
what we're dealing with yeah I don't
know what Tyrese is confused about I'm
guessing he's confused because none of
this information sounds like what he
wants to hear but what happened is very
clear at least clear enough to move on
since we do have like a way to actually
communicate with the real Carmella I do
want to reach out to her maybe they're
working together on their scam the
private investigator wasn't able to give
tyrae any information on Christian who
was allegedly the person behind
catfishing him with pictures of Carmella
which is the information I really wanted
to hear we already knew that someone was
catfishing him with pictures of Carmella
but anyway tyrae says he's not going to
give up he is going to find out who this
Christian guy is I just want to contact
her to see if this is true maybe she
knows him and maybe that'll be my first
step into getting answers and maybe she
could lead me to him like I've come too
far to just stop what is he gonna do
when he finds him though
a part of me hopes he does because that
would be interesting but the other part
of me just wants him to leave it alone
for his safety he doesn't know these
people and it takes a specific person to
scam someone like that
um
he's never heard of curiosity killed the
cat I've come too far to just stop tyrae
goes on to share that he now thinks it's
time to tell the rest of his family what
he's been going through it's so much
harder to tell my mom because she's been
through so much already and I feel like
I'm at an age where I shouldn't be
making mistakes like this oh poor baby
at least now he knows he's been tripping
what you need to tell us
uh I mean it's a long story what
something you went through recently oh
hell yeah my health is okay oh that was
such a mom response and look she's
holding her chest bracing for the worst
and it's just that her son has been
catfished
so like four years ago I met this girl
online and
she lives kind of far away
far away like where
like all the way in Barbados
but you snug off to Barbados last year
last year I went to Barbados yeah but to
see her hey that was the plan
all that was going on when I was in the
hospital yeah Tyrese sister says she
tried to talk him out of going to
Barbados but she figured he might need a
break after all he was going through
with his mom she also adds that she
would have never guessed he went out
there for a girl so what happened when
you got there uh she never showed up
are you serious so what did you ever
talk to her again like what happened I
did I started talking to her again like
a month afterwards because I was kind of
like watching do that girl we were
saying the same thing
I cannot believe you me neither I'm so
shocked they slick got mad at him it's
like we love you but why are you out
here being foolish that's not even half
of it he goes on to tell his mom and
sister that the production crew found
out he's being catfished by a man named
Christian
what and it's this shot right here that
sums up the reaction to Tyrese storyline
as a whole at least that's been my face
majority of the time shocked I don't
believe it mixed up in this I can't
believe it I'm still I'm confused fast
forward tyrae lets them know that he
went to a private investigator and this
woman he thought he was talking to is a
porn star and a cam girl and then you
say he doesn't even know where the
person on Snapchat was
[Music]
because I believe
I believe it
you okay yeah I'm okay but it's just
kind of like
I'm just trying to get closure at this
point
I'm thinking like going back to Barbados
Mama then raised her voice you would
take your last money to go over there
share why this is so
wide it's so hard to just let it go I
did have strong feelings for this person
like we were like we had a lot of like
goals and aspirations that were just
saying like starting a business and like
she gave me like something I never
really had
she
like told me that she loved me and stuff
so
I wonder if he's saying he's never been
told I love you romantically or he's
never really heard that at all it's not
clear but I will say
parents out there I am not trying to
tell you what to do I'm not a parent yet
myself but I suggest
you don't already
tell your kids you love them as much as
possible even if you didn't receive that
type of treatment yourself as a kid from
your caregiver or parent
is so important I've had friends who've
never received that affirmation from
their parents or caregivers and similar
to Tyree
not as extreme they end up looking for
love in all the wrong places or not even
opening their heart to receive love at
all I still believe that the person
behind all the messages is a woman
so I feel like you just talk to this
person one more time because I just want
to know if my instincts are right
that this person loved me the way I love
them if anything else is fake at least
that love was real and I feel like that
would be the closure I need and that's
it it would not be it if you found that
out let's not kid ourselves not too long
ago I read something I forgot from where
but it was basically saying that when we
fall in love we start to feel feelings
that we already have inside of us they
were just dormant and really what the
person who we are falling in love with
is doing is helping us to open up our
hearts so we can tap into those good
feelings that we're asleep
I know it's kind of deep but it's Food
For Thought I think it's an interesting
perspective clearly Tyree is holding on
so tight to Carmella because of the way
she made him feel when it's possible
that she really just helped him tap into
something that was already in him
sometimes I imagine a person who made me
feel really good and they're not in my
life anymore but I allow myself to feel
those good feelings I just take their
face out of it it sounds weird but it's
a way to not be sitting there waiting
for someone to come and make you happy
alright off my soapbox this episode ends
with Tyrese sister and Mom sharing how
bad they feel for him yeah I wish I knew
what this person was at because I'm
ready too yeah I know exactly backed up
bad yeah
he's so nice so bubbly and now to see
him so down you know I feel like he's
heartbroken and I hope he can heal I
hope he can get over this
I know you're gonna find love or
whatever like that but don't go back
over there if you even got the chance to
even see this person in real life what
would you even say
I don't know yet
there's so many questions that I have
that I want to ask but he's not trying
to answer them but he just won't give a
straight answer I definitely think he's
holding on to some type of hope that
maybe it could work out for real
hey yep my heart goes out to him but
where I come from they say a hard head
makes a soft
you know it
a soft behind and the fact that we are
still somewhat at the beginning of the
Season
we have a lot in store all right next
week Gino and Jasmine go to therapy oh
thank goodness you know I only have one
week and a half left together
so we need to see a therapist I'm not
satisfied sexually in this relationship
he has even
comments about
my private parts oh you made me feel
rejected these are the kind of things
have any desire to be with her do you
want this to work
hopefully these two can make some
progress
all right 90 days and Sam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time